bonjour bonjour et bienvenue à agen à
juin 2016 championnat de france d'échecs
et bien je suis avec le nouveau champion
de france siècle le grand maître
international mathieu cornette bonjour
mathieu
bonjour bonjour c'était la dernière
partie aujourd'hui un suspense de fou
parce que l'incroyable toutes les
parties étaient super temps du super
intéressante
tu jouer contre le champion en titre
christian bauer comment tu vas voir une
partie par ailleurs pas très bien mais
non mais christian je le connais depuis
des années j'ai je crois que j'ai
regardé à peu près ni on a dû jouer une
quinzaine de parties j'ai dû perdre cinq
fois en gagner une
oui mais j'ai gagné les dernières avec
les blancs et avec les blanches qu'on ne
s'est pas perdue peut-être une fois mais
je me rappelle pas mais avec les blancs
je sais que ok je peux avoir ma chance
après je préparais concret sens c'est
impossible genre hier j'ai regardé à peu
près son arbre il pouvait à 6b 6 6 2 6 2
6 7 6 9 6 et 5 e 5 pts et 5 donc j'ai
essayé de tout regarder mais c'était un
peu long jamais vraiment réussi donc
après voilà je savais que je devais
m'occuper de ma partie il est très fort
et je devais faire un parti après
espérer des résultats positifs
quand on fait une partie pareil que ça
dépend aussi des parties des autres
puisque en fonction des résultats des
autres ça pouvait influent résultats
jean françois joly sa partie ainsi que
face à donc sébastien bazin que tu
connais bien il a dû conduire montrent
inquiètes page il m'a dit t'inquiète pas
mais je me suis inquiété car et parce
qu'il fallait qu'il fasse au moins un
nul face à lui pour pourri c'est pour te
permettre éventuellement de l'emprunt
était de 3 ex-aequo en tête donc ça
dépend des dons en fait du coup je me
suis pas
pris la tête comme citibank et moi je
donne mon parti et je verrai après parce
que si je perds dans tous les cas pas ma
guerre ouais d'accord il fallait que je
joue si je faisais mais je faisais nul
mais la preuve je sais j'avais fait nul
j'aurais de départage pas été si mauvais
et voilà si j'ai une chance de gagner
mais céda saisir tout voilà donc on
regarde pas trop trop les parties on y
jette un oeil quand même en fait j'ai
quand même fini à 7 oh oui c'est vrai du
coup la pression était sur eux la
pression était heureux et ils n'ont pas
tenu finalement l'impressionnant
moi-même au fise armand oui et non c'est
hyper stressant plein fouet
on peut se saouler faut pas se mentir
tous les trois on n'était pas du tout
favori bon les dernières avec vous on
avait fait un bon tournoi mais on
pensait pas forcément je le testerai
donc on n'a pas l'habitude de gérer ce à
quoi on de gérer un stressé le rock
c'est par ici puisque christian de qu'à
l'habitude
il a quand même fait une partie moyenne
oui oui c'est vrai mais bon c'est pas
facile avec lui pour lui parce qu'il est
noir exactement fallait gagner et de
gagner donc forcément il a dû prendre
des risques et ça a finalement ça t'a
servi puisque tu as pu toi même en
jouant une belle partie b en train de
profiter de cette tension pour peut-être
pour marquer un point qui est décisif
portant et des importants à 10,6 me rend
peut-être au garden party pour donc le
nouveau champion deux fois parce que
c'est un nouveau nom dans le palmarès
maintenant mathieu gornès le champion de
france et tu rejoins l'aquitaine laurent
frayssinet et jean-luc serait non mais
je n'étais pas content ouais enfin moi
j'ai joué avec lui quand j'étais gamin
mon club donc je les ai connus comme le
chemin de france de bordeaux parce qu'il
jouait à bordeaux échec pendant un
accord n'était pas originaire qui était
henri jouer pour le club en mai 2
bordeaux et
il ya je le serai grand maître et
d'aquitaine en aquitaine un acte 2 voilà
il y en a que deux on fait vite le tour
tu es le deuxième est donc un titre
national dans un des plus grands
championnats nationaux ou du monde donc
le dis en lice que la france rappelons
le c'est la quatrième ou cinquième
nation sur la planète aux échecs c'est
parti pour mathieu donc aux 4 j'avais
décidé de jeu 4 comme l'année dernière
et beaucoup de questions je joue tout le
temps un catho qui est là tout de suite
boom qu'a vivre si c'est bizarrement j'y
ai pensé
donc j'avais regardé deux minutes
tranquilles hirson parce que si la
liquide et on peut dire que là les kings
dans des tournois majeurs elle est jouée
au team un peu comme préval faut vous
dire c'est christian reid a besoin de
gagner et après christian il aime bien
se reprendre
donc en général pour se préparer quand
il faut regarder les coquilles a pas
joué récemment il ya plus de chances que
ça arrive
donc si les réponses et donc ok j'ai
joué juste que moi je j'ai joué pendant
la base d'avoir plusieurs partis comme
ça d'accord classique sur la liquid
s'éprend des 600 mhz associé de l'autre
cookies et plus anciens qui est
peut-être un peu plus compliqué mais je
prends c'est le cou à la mode très
solide
gecimed sa garde les soutes sur simon st
gall et christian il s'en fout un peu la
symétrie je pense qu'ils voulaient c'est
garder des pièces sans réalisateur
qu'ils gardent des pièces comment ça
c'est important
ok donc moi je me suis dit il c'est être
préparé mais dans tous les cas je vais
jouer ce que je connais je voulais j'ai
pas cherché plus loin ce que je pense
que j'ai déjà cette position dans la
base ok là il ya la fois m6 il a fauché
quatre ya juste un truc important hamon
a expliqué qu'avec les b4y ci qui peut
paraître pour les noirs qui peut
paraître logique il faut bien koubéens
est sûre qu'est prince et cathya dames 1
4 on a fait échec le 10 pièges sur
cavaliers prend keller de gagner un pion
bien sûr il ya la classique dames à
carde échec
eh oui si on revient avec lecavalier et
à l'autre car c'est l'autre qui est à
offrir un joli petit piège il faut pas
tomber dans ce piège là évidemment c'est
un tout petit peu embêtant et donc de
coût il a joué rock existe
ok donc là il ya un autre cas maison qui
avait quatre corps un piège et n'ont
donc cavalier bekkaoui pardon toujours
pareil délicate jfb un bébé français 4
il prend comme a encore trois à 3 sa
chasse oui si on commence à avoir l'idée
qu'à et c6 idem de trouver là dans les
caves et on va montrer quand même
regarder hop ça attaque bien sûr la
classe d'âge cette matrice again le
cabinet cice cavalli perdu faux
pareilles matez donc on prend le
cavalier ensuite piaggio qui lâche des
fripes 6 donc souhaité 6 b 3 parce que
si je joue au train manon kébé 4,9 et
mange la paire de fou d'accord qui
maintenant ce fameux coup il faut auquel
il faut toujours faire attention voilà
ggb 3 parce qu'ici le coup peut-être le
plus solide c'est qu'elle prend des cats
mais ça donne une position légèrement tu
vas prendre achète exactement parce que
cavalier prend cavaliers prend c'était
une partie de mon ami hedi piché ski 1
et upa vaujany l'année dernière et je
pense un peu mieux pour les blancs moi
je voulais je vois là je voulais une
pression de cet avantage sans risque
avec leur one peu faibles volumes en
confiant je pense un peu donc là je te
rude que le coût normal qu'au tournoi
que je connaissais donc faut être entre
autres un fou j'ai quatre cartes où le
cavalier qui protège des quatre idées
qu'elle est là un cliché très longtemps
et auquel je m'attendais à des 5
oui on va voir ce qu'on s'était dit
alors des scènes qu'un coup thématiques
dans la donne a dit qu on joue des
cercles en cas de ses serres le
qu'arrivant seller vite prendre un
arrêté
je m'attendais à des cinq c5 je
m'attendais qu'ils prennent à eux deux
mais en fait j'ai regardé hier 2030 qui
m'ont rappelé que j'avais préparé
ok là j'ai flashé que je connaissais pas
ou du moins je me rappelais pas on peut
être qu'il peut pas forcément théorique
non plus mais en fait ma copine m'a dit
que christian bale jusqu'où il ya dix
ans ah parce que la regarde elle est
passée donc ta copine
joue aux échecs c'est une information
qu'on savait pas je me marie avec
d'accord et les 2400 l ennemi donc le
temps les gens ont commencé à la
connaître ça commence à être convoqués
jantes là le coup que je au début je me
pensais jouer f3 ouais mais il ya des
simples si j'ai pas de beaucoup d'encre
f3 avec l'idée si forget 6-3 4-6 le
fougueux g6 le fauteuil tout est faux
dans la partie d'ailleurs mais là le
problème c'est qu'il ya des 5 et je
pense qu'il est noir sont bien j'ai joué
qui avait failli être ok j'ai fait
manger la paire de flou voilà tu me
prends la paire de fou c'est ce qu'on
s'était dit choqué - 5
la paire de fouet perdu donc ils obligés
de manger 4 il faut qu'à très bon coup
parce que dans le rush des saints oui
parce qu'on s'était dit faut deux
frustrant mais c'est ça ce n'est pas
assez rapide
alors que l'afrique est gentil je vois
la tour b 8 mois qui est normal mais ton
oui puisque ça défend bessette pour
libérer le cavalier c6 hockey est donc
là en fait ça c'est la position critique
de la partie ici je suis sûr à 100% du
bon coup ça m'a été confirmé dans le
sens propre il faisait ça mais
honnêtement pendant la partie j'étais
sûr que le bon coup et des jaquettes
d'accord j'étais sûr avec l'idée c'est
que l'état empêche la f5 qui peut être
en cours sans doute ajouter valeur en
tout à fait la main en fait l'idée c'est
que je nageais 5 et une pièce j'empêche
qu'avec 5 et 6 des cinq keller un coût
qui peut être intéressant mais ici je
peux simplement bouger le fou ou f3 ou
g2 est en fait au prochain coup en f3
peut-être sans doute et j'en avais 5 et
du coup je vais gagner des saints donc
j'ai quand j'étais sûr que c'était long
mais la jeunesse m on va juste dire se
fout il peut pas sortir complètement
prix nobel a donc en gros je suis sûr
que j'ai capté le bon coup mais le
problème c'est que j'ai bon il peut
jouer n'importe quoi il peut bouger qui
revenir avec lecavalier et j'ai cassé un
os compromettants et j'avoue que
j'ai eu peur de jusqu'où j'ai eu peur de
calculer des cinq c5 ou qui avaient eu
peur de me tromper et donc du coup j'ai
joint un coup bizarre enfin bizarre j'ai
jean paul logique mais ici tu as joué 5
est en fait c'est sa part aux et oui
parce qu'on est ici posée est en fait
s'il ya une raison psychologique c'est
que je sais que christian amis point de
maintenant et doit gagner et ici en fait
il doit y avait des f-5 que le coup qui
l'aurait vu tous les autres donc tous
les autres tant dans tous les autres cas
et on fait qu'elle est simple tu peux
montrer les amis de co reims et ça tu as
et psychologique donc s'il avait joué
ici cavaliers f5 joseph précise vous
prend même si l'on prend probablement au
passage ici il ya une vingtaine maison
de fous prend 17 est intéressant ici
tout de suite il faut prendre 17 parce
que les plans peuvent pas prendre la
pièce les noirs peut pas promettre si
ils prennent ainsi ils prendront d'abord
et à oui il faut que l'un d'abord 1 md
sur tout à fait une tour prends mes
lumières que ses patrons ce premier
dakar et elle se situe prend 1,17 et
maintenant si on prend 17h08 aux échecs
sui 2 h 7 cv des requêtes suffit de kg
sera quelques attaques la dame et menace
1 angers st kisito rage suite et ensuite
en effet gratuitement et à tout rachat
suite m'a tout de suite mais ça marche
pas fort en 17 ce qui peut prenant des
quêtes fin ça marche pas c'est juste ça
donne alors si ça ne marche pas parce
qu'il semblerait qu'elle fait simplement
d'en prendre quatre y prend un pion
central et c'est par un spécial mais du
coup dont j ai pas premier ça j'avais
prévu sur deux alpages de [ __ ] en
baisse est ici devant m6 d'un premier
jet serait juste simplement fou prend
explique fu prend cavaliers tout
simplement
et si tu penses que c'est ça qui me fait
peur c'est ça c'est de la main d'un
produit on prend je sais pas et pour
prendre huit t3 et c'est nul et ça va
être nul mais je les limites je suis un
peu mieux là j'ai peut-être quelques
scènes trop de simplification l'egypte
accueille bilingue mais imaginons puis
on prend un accent qui si vous avez un
peu plus logique
oui ici ce que je te reprend 1,8 on
ramène un pion vers le sens je te dire
l'avantagé riad est reproduit tous
reprendront tour 30
touron quand même apprendre tout reprend
d'un trop grand d'être un geek est il ya
des quatre en l'air mais il va y avoir
un mythe accordables 8 il ya un échec
perpétuel s'est scindé m'évite saddam
huit échecs rachète le roi est un chef
cette dame français 3 est maintenant si
la dame
il n'y a pas de tension n'y a pas de
couloir 1 on faire gaffe et demi
maintenant perpétuelle est en fait donc
j'ai vu ça mais je sais crise on a vu
aussi et j'étais sûr qu'il allait pas
contré nancy ça tue le avis et c'est là
c'est là que la position dans le tournoi
rentrer en jeu et c'est à dire que comme
comme il doit absolument gagner pour
avoir une chance de jouer les départage
et donc de garder son titre il va pas
rentrer 17 mais je pense qu'après h4 les
blancs sont venus h 400 goncourt
s'explique russe entre beaucoup acheté à
petit je pense que les blancs sont
brusquement quand il prend je vais
prendre du plomb avec mon objectif c'est
d'enlever les cases de ses cavaliers
dans les bacs il a joué ces six que
logique je pense ça va encore tordeuse
sinon ceci a commencé la partie 2 normal
que je vais doubler
tu va doubler sur la colonne bien sûr
ici je m'attendais à dame b sides un
match ici je pense qu'il a fait une
bêtise il a fait n'est grave erreur d'un
v6 met la pression sur des cadrages a
tourné un
c'est pas mauvais de mettre des toros en
regarde là je pense qu'il a joué une
erreur il a fait qu'ils exportent d'être
trop passifs trop passive quand c'est
jésus il ya peut-être rien à peut-être
ils vont venir eux aussi ce pour un bien
c'est un an mais il veut faire quelque
chose mais je crois juste que ça marche
pas ça c'est bien joué prise prises
auront bientôt un ok donc l'idée c'est
que s'il fait cavalier e 6 je lui
balance des 5-6 que valeo 6 bat oui tu
va profiter de l'encombrement
discussions là sur la sur la colonne ici
dessin qui s'était notion prend et
fillon prenant non non non je reprenais
une pièce tu reprends d'une pièce fou
aux cavaliers est ce qu'on se fout
complètement l'union alors pour quelle
raison parce que ça devienne meilleure
structure et gèle attaque j'ai la
colonne russe assez faible ces sahraouis
tu veux pas désorganiser puis on en est
sûr qu'il agira j'essaie donc on sent
que c'est déjà ça y'a un truc qui va pas
dans son concept et la d5 c'est un bon
coup encaissé pas le coup stratégique on
a envie de jouer
pourquoi parce que j'aimais le pion sur
case blanche
oui mais tant l'aide des cases aux
cavaliers exactement je sais que j'en
avais la cage de 6 et je me dis que son
cavalier aura beaucoup de mal à aller 5
voilà sa sombre et valier là il est un
peu hors jeu quoi parce que même si
virage 7 il est coincé par le pillage 4
et où il ya un dessin je pense est ce un
bon coup là sans l'aide des cases et ses
cinq ans c'est trop compromettants ici
je pense que tout est bien beau -
peut-être genre des jeux poussée de
bouger le fou d'abord finir avec l'idée
de clouer le cavalier sur vous
j'ai joué ça d'abord là je pense que son
meilleur coup était cavalier ses 8 mai
avec un coup comme casser vite su peut
être que mieux quand même
oui ça c'est hyper passif face à couper
tour mais là je pense qu'il a fait
notre erreur mais là je pense d'un défi
cats étaient peut-être pas le plus
précis bon ok c'est quand même beau un
beau coutumes et la dureté avant cela
drame quand tu vas de vendre devant du
roi tu mets la pression sur des systèmes
nas cavale et b5
donc si je fait qu'ils avaient faim
qu'ils menacent ce cas les personnes qui
attaquent des six 6 à 7 quand même déjà
je pouvais le faire mais kébé 5e' jeu
tour 5 quai prince est évidemment nos
sept et il essaie de doubler les aides
désactivées liste qui nous du coup je
pense que ça c'est un bon coup c'est en
fait ici je menace reproche à 6 oui oui
on l'a vu ça ouais on avait vu cette
variante est ce qui est joli
parce que fou prend alors oui alors
imaginons qu les noirs jouent un coup
comme à six exactement ce que je veux
mais skype est simple parce que tu me
laisses frange essaya fou prendre g6 et
alors l'idée c'est que ces deux tours l'
attaquent la tour 8
c'est à dire qu'il est à deux reprises
ici à tout reprend et ça gagne la dame
et contre le retour au pays est fou mais
c'est bon pour les blancs donc et si ils
prennent d'abord en se disant psy
reprend évidemment je gagne ou dessous
mais non échec à la déco l'admr exemple
en d2 moi ou n'importe quand n'importe
où je serai leur rêve sans échec de la
dame d'abord une laura bush avant que
j'ai gagné le pion gcc on a gagné un
pion hyper important puisque le roi on
le voit là il est tout nu non mais ça
c'est en effet l'âge de tosse auquel
elle je pense que si on met un coup de
main d'homme 17
il m'a demandé après la partie mesdames
les sept en fait tu peux jouer de cause
je peux jouer déjà f4 comme dans la
partie pour jouer pour f5 et où quand je
peux aussi choqué et b5 ici et cavani b5
à peine un pion fait oui oui oui
tour 5 et prendre l'a7 et après je
reviens et mon idée c'était de jouer une
finale g unit pions set c'était mieux
qu'est ce qu'il a fait mais ouais c'est
pas un tout petit peu mieux mais il est
déjà moins bien
souffre là pour être simple donc solide
et voilà ce qu'est b5 maintenant il fait
assiste donc je fais f4 voilà la tour
ici bloquent l'action de la dame sur le
bilan des six mais l'exercice est notre
coup c'était tours 7
oui voilà on se dit qu'il est venu là on
va voir que c'est un problème mais on
s'était dit peut-être en 7 il est
protégé par le cavalier donc métaux n'y
a pas de découvertes sous projets sa
norma jackpot en apparence dans ma tête
ça perdait face à part dénoncer je
pensais de bons doublages celle qu'on
peut jouer aussi f5 sans doute
j'ai beau essayer d'ouvrir le jeu ou
cabinet bcg evry 5e non je pense que tu
as raison tu as we can be seen ça marche
partout mais là ces a la chance que je
sens tout âge 5.5 h&h alors h5 pour
casser le la défense moi mais là c'est
qu'il peut pas jouer quel gâchis puisque
je peux jouer avec toujours un actif au
projet c'est ça ton et la folle si oui
parce que sinon alors si alors admettons
qu'ils tout ça tient alors dans ce cas
la prison g6
il prend pas de cavalier sinon il perd
quelque chose si j'ai dû prendre du but
rennais ce que le foot pro hélas quand
même fou prend lescouarc'h la recette
mais ici prendre que le cloud et bien
sûr les clous et ci et là c'est la même
c'est la même parce que là le cavalier
mais will calais protège plus donc h5
ici c'est très difficile de trouver un
bon donc il faut que le cas les restes
là pour garder la tourbe glauque et
chute reste là pour défendre g6 donc il
faut admettons qu'ils jouent à 6 inquiet
d'un coup et maintenant voilà c'était
sound et j'apprends alors on prend
maintenant tu comprends qu'ils ont surfé
fou prend quand même ça doit jouer 5
c'est ça exact mais là il y avait les
prend et l5 et f5 et malgré le fait
qu'ils aient ça c'est pas grave on va
prendre de la dame avec un roi
complètement défoncée durant la wii
c'est déjà en sicile
c'est qu'il ajouterait sont donc je tour
à charles prow entourage 5 videmment
sait que sa tour va être hors jeu
tu vois là tu voi alex tu va la mettre
sur à l'ouest soit éloignée une vente
amusante ici je tour agissent pour
défendre contre ce que j'ai fait dans la
partie moyenne ici je peux gagner de
façon je lis que je kébé saint calais b
cinq attaques n'ont toujours pas alors 1
6 1 6 tours 8
et alors pour que kalinka vente pour
apparaître pour prendre d'ici salvatore
vitale est d'accord notre dame prend
donc là il faut il faut donner sinon on
perd la tour donc te reprend on donne la
tour la dame contrôles du tour général
sabah hockey prend des 6 mai et l'asie
proches gagnantes auront peut être d'une
qualité académique
oui c'est la tour bouge maintenant il ya
cavaliers f5 échec au roi évidemment la
dame clou le purger six et donc sa perle
à tour donc il est obligé d'aller en
achète donc il calcule tout donc sur
donc il a joué fouet trois tours à
château 26e alors ce don qui jouent ils
obligés d'aller acheter t il par un seul
idc qui l'accablé agissements voilà il
faut sortir son cavalier essayer de
s'activer puisqu'ici via l'écran le
curage 4,6 mais on est là par contre
l'attaqué trop forte
f5 donc là il joue quand même que la
chine c'est sa seule chance nous fouet
parce que calais 17 le pion des six
était en prison tout à fait ok là
peut-être phu cat est encore plus fort
peut-être x 15 pour remettre le fouet
mais bon ce que j'ai fait j'ai vu la
partie semble salaires bon tout à fait
donc là laquelle il peut jouer qu'à les
scènes qui attaquent la dalle à
marseille ou intermédiaire on est rentré
dans la grande variante leur mf4 donc
ici d'un f4 attaque le calvados et la
torture en prison
la toux rauque est d'abord on y voit pas
d'âme j'écarte parce que tu vas le voir
après d'accord la séquence est su
ménager cat way i fé qui me prend et oui
et donc je fais h 5 h salle jean une
pièce en fait voilà alors oui h 50 rue
jules est de prendre un g6 qu'attaquer
lecavalier la tour et tu pourras pas te
défendre exactement et le seul coup
logique contre guillemets qui défend
tous ok si fait cahier des cats
maintenant j'ai tour de cet échec et
dames drive si c'est pour ça que j'ai
mis la dame en aa oui et pas un g4
l'étonnante admettons voilà et admettons
cavaliers des quatre retours échec
moi j'évite et la dame prend un f6
protégeant la tour et menaçant des maths
partout enfin ou des échecs en fait tout
un tas de trucs comme la ya peut-être
qu'à les cinq ans peut-être là tout le
cavaly pour peut-être que ça c'est pas
le plus précis peut-être qu'il faut que
j aurai pour une pseudo gagner quand
même puisque tu vas prendre annonce tu
peux pas il ya là demain
attention ça c'est pas le plus précis
pont
mais tu peux prendre peut-être tout est
un papa jesse sadek le pion quand même
et oui c'est un peu moins clair
peut-être d'accord donc sur h5 qui sont
décalées t4 id crédible je pensais que
ça perdre et h si ça marche pas ça à six
parce que s'il prend de la tour pour
tours 7
et la tour et non en fait là je fais tu
apprends h7 tout simplement et en rêve
étrange ici c'est fiat et je vais mater
s'il prend du cavalier tu prend du plomb
une déci prend du roi puis on prend
quand même du pion et après l'épreuve
qu'elle attend lui de prendre de leur
cavale et prend tout simplement clou je
pense gouache sadok enix cavaliers
leucate aussi à bout revenant jean roux
a lui plongé six cavaliers ou quatre ici
à leur fort aux cavaliers et je sais pas
il faut j'aurais dû calculer attaque et
six attaques tout en papier j'ai pas
trop d'autres que ce soit gagnant
quelque part mais justement et j'ai pas
bien j'ai pas vu que c'était un trou
s'est enquis la jeune homme décède
qu'est le coup logique mais pour
défendre le kf5 mais ça permet une pièce
après jk parce que le cavalier peut pas
bouger il ya tours 7
oui donc pas la partie enfin je n'ai pas
vu notre coup que j'ai quatre sites il y
avait déjà quelques éclairs très bon
aussi mais voilà mais bon j'ai quatre
gagné une pièce que là tu menaces pions
pranger si c'est le deuxième cinq qui
éclot sur la dame
ouais mais g4 est très fort en tout à
fait déjà partie gagnée
donc il joue encore quelques coups par
inertie par inertie
non ça c'est mignon c'est qu'en fait je
me nomme g3 pourrait changer les pièces
nous ne souhaitons pas pas échanger
c'est ça et maintenant j'étais resté à
peu près des jolies g8 mais il abandonne
la lavande et oui sur dame prend ses
maths en g8
alors là et donc à ce moment-là bon mais
bon déjà content ouais +35 ans
je regarde les positions jeudi les
gagnants et götze gagnant baigne je
pense que jean françois a été agréé une
position du coup oui puisque j'ai reçu
des textos j'ai regardé sur mon
téléphone au 40e coup et ratings alors
est ce que tu te rappelles du coup
peut-être 7 euros 8 échecs le dmg 4g
mais pas vulgaire j'ai juste on a juste
envoyé mais d'abord simple il a dit son
port et chercher des parties sur
internet et en librairie gozzo dans
l'ouverture ratée qui avait les f-5
aussi avec gros avantage et même après
il a fait une très bonne partie plus en
plus et il a pas réussi à le convertir
il n'y a pas eu de chance que dans la
finale il se retrouve à quatre points de
plus mais le bila vallier est très bien
placé il fait une sorte de forteresse où
ils vont se demander si ça avait l'air
mauvais son plan d'échangé contre le cas
jusqu'en asie qui l'a pas trop quoi
faire de l'élitisme
il fait ce qu'il fallait pas qu'ils
essaient d'avancer ses pions la dares le
sort est éminemment échangé le fou quand
ils pensaient avoir encore des chances
de bien après mon cas mais les bains
finale deux tours très difficile donc
bon résumé parce que là c'est aussi
sportif là on a vu la partie technique
c'est bien mais sûr mais ça te fait un
super tournoi tu as fait qu'une défaite
je fasse ça le surprenant jean françois
joly qu'est ce que tu en penses aussi de
son parcours en métal en tant que
champion de travail à la partie contre
lui j'ai fait juste une longue partie
parce que dans une paix sont enterrés
que je connais je décide de jeu cas et
décès qui n'existent pas inventé un plan
sachant que je connais qu'elle g8 le bon
coup et je connaissais encore 5,6 coup
de théorie mais juste en fait j'ai fait
mon parti je me suis mis trop de
pression j'ai pas honnêtement j'avais
pas d'armé la lune j'étais trop stressée
je n'avais pas l'habitude et a réussi
derrière à reprendre mais du coup je me
suis dit bon berger perdre à perdre j'ai
perdu contre joli mais bon le freaks
paulo forum le félicite et je les
remettrai je les félicite et y apportant
sa norme et où il atteint super tournoi
il élude moi je réalise pas en france
mais il réalise pas forcément le temps
qu'il a fait c'est incroyable qui finit
troisième
willy troisième là où
mais à d'autres moments où il a fait
rêver beaucoup d'amateurs cgc moi je le
connais bien falaise les jauges pas de
france jeunes plusieurs fois ouais donc
ces jouets de dix enfants non plus
j'avais toujours gagné contre vue et là
c'est la jme se fait déchirer ce moment
au mauvais moment
non mais ces coûts de ce qu'il a fait en
fait je pense que qui a joué pour lui ça
a été le déclic c'est de prendre parti
le rien de plus dur que rentrer dans un
tourment ouais donc je vois qu'on
appelle le rôdeur ou quand il avait joué
j'avais jeu on avait gagné et c'est dur
après vraiment la ronde 1 il joue
gharamian et s'est fait dominer il est
foutu et ya nul les deuxièmes parties
gainbourg à partir de là tu permets
arrivée et après il a joué sans complexe
il a joué les échecs qui sait jouer
offensif sans se poser de question et
s'il a fait un super tournoi et il
mérite d'être là et on le reverra
l'année prochaine donc super bref voilà
c'était aussi une aussi nos belles
surprises il ya deux belles histoires du
championnat en fait plusieurs y en a
plusieurs
non j'étais la 3d histoire c'est super
beau jour voilà enfin yannick c'est un
ami il a fait un super tôt mais je pense
il a mon avis l'apartheid vambre quand
on est venu aux commentaires l'autre
jour c'était vraiment pas une bêtise ce
n'était pas une elle a rangé ses loyers
vraiment on avait prévu de jouer il
s'est reparlé 15h54 est juste et il a
stressé mais on n'a pas tous les jours
qu'on a je pense qu'il a stressé aussi
fière parce que hier il est engorgé pour
le gagner c'est vrai qu'il nous faut
lisser six ans dans le sens émanant mais
il ya pire c'est juste que je lis a fait
une bonne partie des grands ouais aussi
ok il a eu des réussites je lis la
guinée contre 2 minutes la finale très
joli mais qui est complètement nulle la
finale normalement elle est très jolie
élise est complètement non qu'il ait eu
eux aussi interdits mais on a besoin de
réussite pour bien entendre moi j'ai eu
la réussite contre laurent chez un peu
moins bien
ouais après j'ai réussi à bien défendre
lierre aussi tigran même la pression
j'ai dû défendre mais ça s'est pas trop
mal passé hébreu voilà c'est un grand
moment un grand moment en grand danger
si ce sont mes terres voilà je j'avais
réfléchi quand tu as la porte après fois
je suis venu un agent pour un tour
d'échec j'ai dû faire le championnat
d'aquitaine et de beats il ya deux ans
oui jacques andré et 13 ans 15 ans
et oui oui c'est ma meilleure il ya 16
ans j'avais quatorze nous sommes en
aquitaine et c'est beau de gagner avec
mail je collais vrai je connais couple
et tout le monde ici c'est non c'est que
et patrice etchegaray qui est passé
aussi loin il ya voilà il ya du monde à
tous les aquitains qui sont venus donner
un coup de main mais il ya renault
lagune qui l'a habillé les romans lamine
cissé qui va après josé chèque en ce2 et
oui et après c'était le silence tendu
comme j'étais jeune un important échec à
l'époque oui et non c'est non mais si tu
rêverais de faire de toi là j'ai reçu
des textos et oui les messages des mails
et je vous rappelle d'ailleurs qui
commentait aussi ton parcours je sais
pas si tu te rappelles au grand prix de
bordeaux au 6 août étaient arrivés en
finale
j'avais perdu contre edward aux mains en
ayant fait patte avec dame que donc je
peux d'une tour de plus et un beau grand
pape s'était déjà renault qui commentait
avec là-dessus freyssinet et rené et
avait battu rené sûr avec une tour folle
je rappelle tout avait sauvé une partie
est variable et j'avais battu leur en
demi finale ouais c'est des métiers des
dieux mais c'était au théâtre fémina
bordeaux et qui est en ligne on peut le
voir en vidéo
imaginez son diagonale d'une île
entièrement enregistré exactement super
on est super contents en super content
pour ce oui moi je t'ai connu petit et
déjà tu étais assez le temps est assez
pénible
wen était déjà très accrocheur et donc
voilà on est super contents mission de
de ta victoire de voir que vous ayez un
nouveau nom au palmarès des chefs
français les émissions riches voilà il
ya une génération légal qui est en train
de monter mais il ya une bonne
génération de trentenaires entre
éliminés
il ya sébastien maaseik a fait un très
mauvais tournoi mais bon faut pas
oublier qu'il a fait une année
incroyable il est passé de 1634 eh bien
il a gagné des préjugés baltard
politique n il a fait un travail tout à
fait ok il a fait un mauvais tournoi
mais il sait pas facile de se porter à
100 parce que du coup sûr un coup se
retrouvent favori et voilà du coup non
effet le gozzo moi on se connaît tous
depuis qu'on est gamins
ouais ça fait plaisir plaisir de se
rencontrer de se revoir quand on est un
peu plus grand quand on est devenu
professionnel déchets grand maître
international et puis voilà on a vécu un
beau tournoi je pense que le public
était ravi de vraiment de toutes ses
parties de ce championnat parce que est
très discuté très beau à suivre très
passionnant des parcours vraiment
géniaux le tien aride et des hauts et
des bas avec cette défaite face à face à
jouer au lycée trot monté derrière et
puis ce final parce que gagner contre
champion en titre c'est aussi absolument
génial non mais en plus non mais je
pense que là cette année est parti était
peut-être pas les plus belles après il
faut pas oublier qu'il manque maxime
dumont ketchup laddh mariage du pacs et
je me considère pas comme lumière de
france 1 loin de là il ya un manque
beaucoup de joueurs mais ça reste un
choix de france qui était très très
ouvert très intéressant à regarder des
parties est intéressante et quand on
réfléchit guerra un moment quand on
regarde les positions ils pourront pour
on pouvait se retrouver cinq ex-aequo en
tête
oui c'est vrai c'est incroyable
aujourd'hui quand on a pêché un et cinq
à pouvoir gagner le titre
christian est laurent pouvait encore
revenir c'est incroyable juste bravo
bravo mathieu à granby mathieu
bravo à et c'était donc super
championnat de france 2016 âge
merci de nous avoir suivi sur des
gonades tv c'était la deuxième
participation de mathieu au studio des
bonal tv il avait fait la première est
bien il fait la dernière c'est pas plus
mal
merci à tous au revoir